hello and welcome to our fourth and last
installment of the video guides to
daedalic entertainment turn-based
strategy game blackguards now with the
first three episodes each of you should
be variable Master Technicians and/or
combat monsters and since we can't teach
you anything new in regards of magic
ostia this guide taps into a wholly
different matter actions have
consequences and will tell you how you
influence the story with your decisions
and what calls you have to expect all
right we'll rescue her one way of
influencing the story is through
dialogues their rings true than the
saying the pen is mightier than the
sword in that sense apparently harmless
words can have dire consequences
especially considering the poor anger
management skills of a certain dwarf
norem what bloody Palace your other nosy
little runt root draw your weapon biggin
speaking of which not only the
protagonist can act during dialogues
sometimes the members of your party have
something to say this is indicated by
their name in text send in front of a
dialogue option is simply example early
in the game after reaching the town of
Warren your party encounters a beggar
asking for some spare coins can you
spare a farthing for God's fear in old
man now you can either be the Good
Samaritan or stick to a cheapskate
approach if you choose to be in a
gracious mood the beggar wish has some
secrets with you there's an old
battleground where clever adventurer
and/or vulture can make a lot of money
if you keep your coins they even let
norns boot do the talking you will of
course save some gold go to the Nameless
One what's this world coming to but you
won't know about the better ground
either and never know of all the gear
littering the fields your charisma
attribute also has an impact on
dialogues only at certain charisma
thresholds additional dialogue options
are unlocked if your attribute unlocks
more dialogue this will be indicated by
a charisma tag next to the dialogue
choice
an example for this one upon reaching
Ming Billa you will encounter a thief
threatened by a bunch of facts with a
sufficiently high charisma you can let
Aurelia pull off a trick and get
yourself and the girl out of harm's way
safely hello could you spare a coin what
do you have any money for us you can
also choose to have noram deal with this
delicate matter and you probably figured
out yourself to what end of a
conversation the unmatched diplomatic
skills of the tariff leave your party
this is none of your business airy-fairy
am very fairy battles also have a more
than just pounding your enemies into the
dirt there are also optional goals if
you achieve those you'll earn some kind
of extra reward or the story takes an
unexpected turn that leads us back to
the battlefield mentioned earlier if
your party decides to loot that place of
course you're not the first to have that
idea there is no honor among thieves and
thus a heated battle for the lewodan
shoes in this battle instead of only
killing your opponent's the optional
goal is to open as many tests as
possible each an open chest at the end
of the battle means less loot for your
party if you thought norum requires
special attention and a short leash you
probably missed out on zuber ends
debauchery he likes to play with fire
and we don't mean his spells he's a
ladies man and sometimes his fair
company gets in the line of sad fire
that's exactly what happens to a certain
Baroness heli is on with the lecherous
mage lets her end up in Chains and put
the gallows Zubrin the gentleman he is
of course wants to save the damsel in
distress we must rescue better return
and now it's on the party to stop the
execution to prevail they need to get to
the gallows within a certain number of
turns if they fail well then we'd have a
love story as tragic as it gets save her
however and you'll save the light and
love
Zubrin so yeah okay fine if you're not
the romantic type there's also extra
adventure points in it for you my
Baroness like Grundy quick you must flee
I'll be back yeah whatever come on now
quests also leave room for decisions and
often there's more than one way to go
while traveling your party encounters a
vagabond called or naraz camping in the
wilderness are you headed to tell Eva
that you could do me a favor I doubt it
he claims his brother serena has stolen
his identity now wants you to kill him
after you encounter Serena though you
will claim exactly the opposite his
brother only Andreessen for all he has
achieved I saw your wanted posters you
take care of my brother and I well I
won't tell anyone that you've been
learning his own brother wants to kill
him he asks you to end the treacherous
sibling instead of himself who tells the
truth and who lies and on top of it all
are these two actually who they claim to
be now it's on you to decide if you want
to off one of them right away but dig
deeper to make sense of this mess it's
all up to you and your conscience on
another opportunity the party is hired
to retrieve a powerful magic staff for a
merchant are you athanas kind well then
you can just give them back the staff
and collect your money is this your mask
our own staff Oh wonderful fantastic if
you're more the opportunistic type you
can also keep the stuff it's powerful
after all and Zubrin couldn't be happier
to agree war site with norem would
prefer to see this piece of dark magic
consumed by flames but is that what
you'd want to do spell it he must never
get his hands on the fetish I
wholeheartedly agree I say let's burn
the fetish stuff I wholeheartedly
disagree what was your final call in
these quests are you of the honest sort
or did you act like a true rogue or are
you morally flexible solving each
situation just as you see fit tell us
your story right here in the comments or
the forum
if you're interested in the law of
aventura check out the law of videos of
our friends over at Orkin ta da te nan
durian and he loses games you can also
learn more on our Facebook page our
forum or on the official blackguards
homepage and that's it people now you
should be fully prepared for what lies
ahead and blackguards we hope you
enjoyed the videos got some useful
information out of it and wish you all
the best on your journey across a
victorious y itself and if you still
don't have your own copy of the game
steam gog.com and retail stores of your
choice will gladly provide you with one
if all that fails we are just turn norem
to have a few words with you